well i'm probably not the first to say
this but thank you both for dressing
like so festively for christmas i feel
the spirit through this zoom no you're
welcome yeah
it's a lot of
knitwear
did you coordinate the knitwear for the
zoom or just show up looking like
christmas together oh we got scented we
were sent these clothes we were told to
wear this special festive outfit get
your knitwear on
earlier today with all the you know the
x's and hearts
yeah be glad he's wearing a more muted
color now i mean the luck of the irish
you know
well from um some festive joy to another
deliciously creepy season of servant um
from each of you just a quick tease
what's the audience gonna get yeah it
feels like a very different show i mean
i think there's a lot of new
kind of elements we see a little bit
more outside of the house this time
which is our first kind of glimpse
in of the outside world and um
yeah i mean as well for julian it's very
different he's sobered up he's really
trying consciously to to be a better
person and
to be a healthier person i
start this whole regime of like
exercising things
but also it kind of clears his mind so
he can really kind of face the guilt
that he's been kind of holding on to
um
from the incident which is
yeah i mean it's it's it's i mean that
the core of this show is is about people
who
are not grieving
um so it was yeah really interesting to
to to see that side of him without all
of his
kind of
devices to
to distract him from that
i think it'll be best for everyone if
you were able to make peace with leanne
why are you both so afraid of her
she's angry
i see
please don't hurt her
you're going to get some resolutions
thankfully and you're just going to get
another excellent cliffhanger
although we can't speak that far into it
and you're going to be
well into march before you get there but
yeah it's just it's a trend big
transition for sean he starts to believe
a lot more and see if nurturing nell and
letting her make her own decisions is
the route to getting his family back and
just brushing all this under the carpet
which is an incredibly unhelpful
unhealthy version of of the world so
yeah it's that it's that kind of
we really didn't know what was going to
happen next
and you know it leads you on a great
great great journey well you two seem to
have fun together i was wondering lauren
and now we're telling you know when you
shoot it's intense and it's a lot in a
short amount of time how do you unwind
after a day of filming do you have a
glass of wine do you laugh with your
kids do you laugh with each other what
do you do
it's you know not to be dour but it's
tricky to unwind you know we're in such
a short time period and these are half
hour shows and they're right to the bone
you know there's there's really no no
fat on there at all so we shoot them in
seven eight days sometimes and it's
tricky to come out of it you know it's
really tricky so actually we do a lot of
it on set you know we'll crack a joke
that for some reason every time you
mention it
get to raucous giggles the real goal is
to get you know number one redhead get
her smiling get lauren to just crack if
you can get lauren to crack you we we
have a special prize she doesn't know
about it so don't tell her we have
prizes for getting her to crack you know
usually they're like mini snickers mini
babe roots you know little things like
that but worth it worth it at first i
thought number one redhead was rupert
but that's lauren no he's numbered yeah
[Laughter]
the show also really looks at how far
would you go
for your child as dads yourselves has
that
put any of those thoughts into your head
do you think about you know what people
will do for their families especially uh
when it's all so intense
yeah it's definitely changed my
perspective um since becoming a dad kind
of midway through um just just to really
have a better sense of what that could
do to a family that that kind of
level of loss is just unimaginable and
yeah i mean
it's quite hard for me to really kind of
completely
face that directly i just find it just
incredible and um yeah and it's a weird
place to be
especially when uh when wednesday first
came it was like
i remember i brought to the set actually
on this season she thought she was at
sesame street
which was quite really not so much
very far away from sesame street
but um yeah no it's it's it's really
interesting what a cool moment to bring
your daughter to set that had to feel
like did that feel like a proud moment
oh yeah no amazing i mean um
it's great yeah no i'm i i'm absolutely
loving being a dad it's just the best
thing it's
it's amazing how it completely kind of
takes over
kind of everything it's all i
really care about so it's it's been
great well rupert i i don't want to
shock you but you know i gotta ask you
about this small tiny baby of a reunion
you did
i wouldn't be the person i am without so
many people here
it's a very overwhelming thing because
i've watched you grow up and i've seen
kind of every stage of your life when
things get really dark and times are
really hard there's something about
harry potter that makes life richer
what was it like for you and daniel and
emma to come back was it emotional and
maybe who got the most emotional in it
all what can the fans expect um oh yeah
i mean definitely there's there's
emotions it's
those um movies where our childhood we
grew up on those sets so it has
incredible meaning to all of us i think
and
to see each other again i think it was i
think it's 10 years since we wrapped the
last movie and i mean we've seen each
other quite a bit
between but not not a great deal so it
was it was great to see them again and
talk about it because it's not something
i really can't even think about a lot so
it's it's it's nice to be kind of
reintroduced to it and and to remember
because it was it was
an amazing time it was great fun
any secrets revealed um
well no i'm not sure how much i can say
but it's
it's uh
it's i don't know i can't really say
before but it's
it's every everyone everyone's there
so it's um
it seems like it's gonna deliver
yeah yeah can i ask would you ever
return and play ron as a dad now that
you're a dad yourself
[Music]
um
yeah no i think i mean there's been a
lot of talk of that recently with
everything going on um
so yeah and i feel like i am that
character i have a very strange
relationship in life i feel like he is
kind of
me there's a lot of me in there so it's
i'm quite protective of him so i think
yeah i mean
yeah absolutely i don't really have a
good reason
to say no it's i'm very proud to be a
part of those movies i don't mean to
pipe up and reveal myself as a harry
potter fan that i actually am but you
know he does return as a dad you know
he's a dad at the end when they're at
the train oh yeah
yeah he's already yeah thank you much
that's a good point thank you i'm sorry
basically moody's eye you know no one
ever remembers that but you know
fine you know
i'm sorry i've literally just seen
cursed child on broadway and it's so
wonderful and of course this is making
me think can we get this as a movie and
would daniel and rupert and emma all
come back i'm just picturing this and
i'm fantasizing about it
yeah
no it's a great story i think i don't
know we'll see all right well uh toby
thank you for revealing yourself i'm
gonna assume you're a slytherin because
of the green sweater
the celtics are not happy about that i
mean come on